[Music]
[Music]
the st
louis chess club was founded in 2008 and
the mission has always been three-fold
one to promote top-level chess two
to support a community center where
chess players from around the st louis
area can come and enjoy the game
and three to promote and encourage
scholastic players to enjoy the game of
chess and become lifelong learners
the saint louis chess club couldn't do
what we do we're not for community
support
we're a non-profit organization we
depend almost solely on donations
and in fact some of the students that
benefit most from our programming
are the students at title one schools
where the school itself can't even pay
for the programming
so through the generous support of our
donors we're able to implement
scholastic chess programming and all the
great programming here at the saint
louis chess club seven days a week
you know having chess in schools is
probably the most important part of what
the st louis chess club does
what chess does is it instills all those
important values that are
really good for later in life how to
think analytically you know how to how
to solve
problems
the covet pandemic really hit the st
louis chess club hard back in march
uh we actually closed the chess club
down you know reopening looks so
different these days
we're constantly sanitizing and cleaning
every surface every chess piece
every clock you know really what the st
louis chess club has done since cove it
is take all of our traditional
programming and find ways to move it
online and make it virtual
we have our resident grandmaster who
still teaches weekly here at the st
louis chess club
we have players like national master
caleb denby who
teaching online and playing chess online
in instructive ways
and all of that's happening on the chess
club's youtube and twitch channels
while nobody knows what 2021 will look
like here's something i can promise you
the st louis chess club will continue to
provide all of the great programming
whether it's scholastics club events for
members
or the major events online as well that
you've come to love and enjoy
make sure you check out
uschestchamps.com and st louis
chessclub.org to find out what the next
steps are for the st louis chess club